皆様ブーブークッションというもの
御存知だろうかどんなものかといいますと上に乗るという
お下品な音が出ます乗ってみましょう
[音楽]
car
芸妓んだめっ襟立てたらこの服かっこいい
辞めてもらったとおりだ下品な音がするだろうそうだ
ぜひんだこのブーブークッションなんですけれども同時にを通っ
と嘔吐が大きくなるわけなんですけども何5万円とが大きくなるのかそういうことを
やろうと思ったんですけども
松を見ててください郵便小包ます3個3個
4個5個6個
あー7個8個9号ここまで受けるとバランス的に難しくなるんですよ飲んでも
これはもう何度が脱落入りという感じで中田難しくなってしまいますよって分宮ション
は最大9個くらいしか鳴らせません
残念ですねじゃあ
言う2
うんまあまあ普通の人間ならここで終わってしまうだろう私たちがそう私は思いついて
しまったそうでこれ
バーンでよりんですよを重ねれば重ねるほどたーーーー盛ってちゃってすべての
ブーブークッションがバランスよく真ん中重心を整えてキレイにプレイされるとは限ら
ないのですべっちゃったりして落ちるわけですのブーブークッションが集まりブーブー
クッションを同時に急向上させることは限りなく不可能である
ます
普通にやればねそこで私はひろみそうれすバーンスをとればいいのです
手で今回はこちらは準備しました
こちら
バケツやと白血でございます私はひらめいてしまうさ
このバケツの中にブーブークッション入れますほらもうバッチリぴったりブーブー
クッションのば穴の直径が降ったりですこの版月の中にブーブークッション3つか入れ
てバケツを置いて私が乗ると
てゆーかんずりを登板でます今の原理を利用して僕がこのように塗ることによって全て
のブーブークッションが同じタイミングでバランス崩すことなく焦るをかけられること
もてせめて同罪目で音が鳴るということが起きると思われますたーっと言え今回これね
あのね簡単に見て本当に難しいからねブルーテーション全部同じ第3で鳴らすんだって
ホント先生8呼吸後くらいが限界なので何個
俺の4地区ぐらいあると死んだよん前このブーブークッションが全く同じタイミングで
なることなんて多分
ないよ本当に本当に今日は多分ねすごい歴史にの頃実験をやろうと思っているのでぜひ
皆さんチャベての部分9社の全く同じた3便なる瞬間をその目で確かめてみてください
では以降
癒さすごいていきます
me
この頭悪い様はなぜ悪いバランスまで待ってでも結局
そっと心がけてこの隙間に出たらバランス崩さない気がする
これはイケるでしょ
すごい
4日
ます
完成しましたこちらが某ドンキー本当によっていた部分クッションを全部詰め合わせた
全部が同時に音が鳴るブーブークッション5です
ブーブーオプションバケツですこれが5型超に乗って乗った瞬間すべてのぶーブックス
の同じタイムにの大人になるというわけでございますあの湖から乗っちゃうとこういう
動きになっちゃうからダメなんでこう勢いつけて北へここで扉れますそしたら壁に
こっちからが行くんでどういう飾り方講演彼みたいな子供は下に行くんで
これで完全に音がだけ40人ぐらい同じ
タイミングでそんな時を迎えることはないですか汽笛の版方にはぜひお楽しみください
フィナーレができます
ん
乗ればいいの俺の勝ちできます
ている
まあ
[音楽]
ええええええ
me
いっ
水
っていうまあ
wh
jr
バッ